well welcome man uh first of all how is
this whole process been for you it's
been thirty years of getting to live in
the character as far as the public goes
you know you've done very almost no
press but I mean beyond that not even
doing stuff out of character nobody's
gotten to know you at all as far as the
wrestling community goes you know
outside of the inner circle for people
to kind of see you as mark Callaway is
it a weird thing it's been very weird
you know I've actually it's been a
process because a lot of times
especially early on in this deal I still
found myself being guarded like you know
I can't like I'd want to start to talk
and then I like wait a minute I don't I
don't know if I should say that and then
I had you know then I'd have to process
it all my head and I'm like no this is
this is your idea this is you wanted to
do this so you know let it go and then
because I've always been that guy it's
like I'm the last of the of the kayfabe
guys right like I'm just you know
protect everything at all cost and I'd
be the one in the you know and I'd hear
somebody else talking about the inner
workings of the business or anything
like that I'm the guy in the back lawn
just pulling my hair out and now I'm
that guy so it's it's taking a little
bit of time to kind of get used to that
and but you know it's obviously now it's
it's starting to get a little easier and
and we're kind of starting to scratch
the different layers of who the
Undertaker and Mark Callaway and how
they fit together yeah do the fans like
it or do they get like is it hard for
them to see you out of character or they
are they comfortable with it
you know it's funny most most everything
has been very positive and like you know
people are just because they've you know
they've been dying for years to kind of
for me to lift the veil up and see
what's going on and but then there's
always you know there's always the the
one or two people they're like
my childhood is dead finally you know or
if I did something on social media or
whatever it's like um attackers on
social media my childhood is a waster
man this is yeah
cut me some slack will you are you to
live up to what's that there's a lot of
responsibility for you to live up to
that you're not just doing this for you
anymore like you are responsible for the
childhoods of tens and hundreds of
thousands of now thirty year old men
they're looking Maya for the first live
show that I ever went to was at Wembley
Stadium it was 1992 it was SummerSlam
and that was the show that you came to
the ring in a hearse right in front of
90,000 people a couple of things like
now that I think about that there are a
couple of things about that that are
mind-boggling boggling to me number one
so you were in your 20s when you were
doing that so you're a kid going through
and number two the you'd really only
been in you've been WWE less than two
years at that point and already felt
like oh well that's the Undertaker he's
a staple of this whole thing what was
that like for you at that time to go
through it was just it was utterly
amazing to see that many people and then
coupled with the fact that it was it was
in the UK to you just yeah I was still
like in that whole world of so many
things were being exposed to me and you
know things were such a bigger stage a
big grant you know grander stage but
just I remember on that riding on that
hearse on the way to the ring it's just
like all you could see were people and
you know obviously at that point in my
career that was you know that was what
thirty forty thousand more people that
I'd ever worked in front of at that
point and it was uh and it was it was
like wow this is
pretty damn cool man and then trying to
obviously stay in character and not be a
you know I tried to show any emotion or
any you know how excited I was was I've
always wondered are you what's the worry
is it that you're gonna on your face
crack a smile or like look up and not be
the Undertaker for a second or is it
that oh my god I hope I don't stumble
walking out of this hearse because it
ruins the whole thing I think I think
probably the stumbles were always more
of a you know because that character is
so calculated and so stoic it's just
like and you you know because everybody
is looks like they're their mesmerised
and what you because I move so slow and
this is like what's he gonna do what you
gonna do and yeah if I snap my toe and
you know do the trip run kind of thing
it's it's over it's like oh man he's
just like us but fortunately I didn't
have too many of those through the years
but that was always one of the things
that I was thinking about at when I
walked in especially early on when when
you know when I really felt like I had a
grasp with a character I don't I don't
think anybody could make me make me
smile or bring character but yeah every
once in a while you something might jump
up and Trippi what's it like the first
time you walk out as a catcher
is there a fear the very first time you
walk out in any character that people
won't like it or they won't respond to
it what is that like yeah it was it was
pretty nerve-wracking because I had
spent you know eight almost nine months
in WCW so people had you know they had
seen me and then I had I had a fairly
good break but before I started with
with WTB but you're always kind of like
you know you don't you know you got this
this really strong character and its new
and it's on WWF at the time you know it
so obviously you're nervous because it's
your debut being with a new company and
they've got all this behind you and you
know you don't want to be sitting there
listening to that's me mark that's me
mark you know it's just like ah come on
but it was it was nerve-racking for sure
when did you realize that the position
that you were in in that company or when
did you really get into that position
right because I mean clearly Vince
McMahon had a fondness for that
character from the very beginning I mean
you know from the huge debut to the fact
that you had a victory over Hogan within
a year of you being there but you know
there are all these stories of Vince
liking something and then you know kind
of getting tired of it or it not panning
out like you thought you would or
whatever and he loses interest and
that's it it's it's it's it's goodbye
when did you realize no I'm I'm a staple
here this is this is my position I'm one
of the top people forever yeah it was I
still didn't have that feeling when I
beat Hogan I I was I knew I was coming
up but I wasn't there yet I did you know
I was still kind of like all right I'm
I'm just doing what I'm told and and you
know hopefully this thing keeps - keeps
developing it was probably about the
time I did the probably would be the
angle I did with Jake that was probably
when I felt like okay we have something
here and there was a large you know
there was a large movement to turn that
character babyface right and that was
done the audience you know our fans did
that you know they didn't have any I
don't think anybody when they originally
thought of that character ever thought
of it turning babyface I mean it was it
was just too too dark and too McCobb
especially for the time that we were
doing it and then you know next thing
you know I'm I'm getting cheered and it
was just like this is a sick world out
here do you worry at all before you turn
babyface in that first year when I mean
you're skyrocketed like the first big
angle you have is with warrior and then
you have the angle with Hogan and it's
like you're working with the top people
from the very beginning does it ever
occur to you if I don't become a good
guy I'm running
pop good guys to work with if I don't
become a good guy where does this
character go after Hogan's done and
Warriors done the only place that goes
down right yeah you have to you have to
think like that but at the time I wish
you know I didn't dwell on it too much
we still we had a you know there was
still a pretty good influx of talent
coming in and going out
obviously Hogan and warrior were one and
two on the totem pole but you know I
knew that the I knew there were legs
there but I didn't get too overly
concerned now probably if I knew what I
knew now then I would have probably been
a little bit like okay that's the top
two guys where we you know where we had
but obviously you know there were guys
like Jake and the that was a perfect you
know darkness you know Jake was a dark
character and so you know sometimes
ignorance is ignorance is bliss because
you you can't worry about too much but
it is what it is and it worked out it
worked out all right I guess early on
did you do you ever worry about getting
caught doing Undertaker things like in
flike the fans like like you know you're
crying in a Julia Roberts movie or
whatever it is that you're doing it
doesn't fit and you would have to worry
about them seeing you doing that
absolutely man I don't think he'd ever
caught me crying at the Julia Roberts
movie but that's just my own example for
that no but yeah but like I said I lived
this character like I mean I was
Undertaker 24/7 so I was always
cognizant of you know what are you doing
how are you you know how are you moving
and it's just like you know I don't want
somebody you know seeing me going and
ordering a smoothie or you know I was
like there's a lot easier back then
obviously because there was no you know
there was a cell phones and everything
you did wasn't being with
courted nowadays there's just no I
there's just no way you can do it
anymore but back then it was a little
easier and my focus you know I I knew
what I wanted to do I had this mindset
of you know this is what people are
gonna see so you know I mean I actually
thought like I would be in my hotel room
thinking about okay this is you know
this is what this is how you need to be
when you're going through the airport
this is what you need to be at the
rental car place and you know if we did
any outside media like okay what is okay
I gotta let pallbearer
you know he's got to do the the gist of
the of the talking and and you know I'm
just there for make people uncomfortable
yes even when you look back at photos
that have now come out because
everything's on the internet now and you
look at photos of like you hanging out
with the boys in that era and you're
backstage and you're on a bus or
whatever it's the it's it's completely
it's it's a photo from somebody's
private photo album but you still even
in that photo that no fan would ever see
you have this element of the character
you're in all black you got the hair
down you got the shades on like there is
still it still looks like you're the
Undertaker how long how long would a
person have to be around before they
kind of got to know you backstage well
yeah I made a point early on like our
crew and and our roadies everybody I
mean I always made a point to you know
go up and say hello to them
but before they you know before they got
to to the back of the bus and the
European tours which I think's wouldn't
pictures you're referencing it took a
long time before I felt comfortable
letting anybody back there you know I
mean it was just because that's there's
a little even though I still look like I
know that's kind of where you let your
guard down and you kind of let that you
know you take that deep breath and
exhale and and you you know you have a
you have a moment with your your friends
and your peers but I
really had you know I had to trust
people and and most of those guys
understood what I was trying to do and
you know and they all I got I can't say
that there's really anybody that that
was like well I'm gonna try and you know
I'm gonna try and expose him for this or
that you know they understood and they
understood the importance of the
character and most you know everybody
obviously wanted to you know they wanted
to do angles anyway so it was right you
know but I was pretty I was pretty
guarded pretty most of the time but I
wasn't I didn't you know I wasn't like
if you know some rigor came by you know
I wasn't like I always felt like it's
important to treat people you know
people treat people the way you want to
be treated but I came understood that
okay this this is how he is and you know
isn't this easier less pressure easier
at this point it's it's it's much easier
and you know even even Michelle now will
tell me he's like kind of liked it more
when you didn't talk so much yeah you
went you went through this period of
time is I mean it's pretty long as most
of your career I think where I think you
were viewed is so dependable in WWE and
a person that would not only always be
there but would always deliver on a
certain level that you started getting
every opponent thrown at you that
whether they could wrestle or not if
they look like a monster it would be
like a guy would come in and be an
undertaker opponent we were talking
about this before you came on about how
you know you ended up having to drag
eight-foot guys through WrestleMania
matches and having a you jury or your
orbital socket broken by 600-pound man
dropping his leg on your face
did you get to a place where you were
like look Vince I appreciate that you
think I'm dependable but please please
let me work with some of these guys that
know what they're doing
oh yeah man I begged him all the time I
was this like it was funny because I
knew like when somebody would come in
they'd be like Oh
even before even before I got that I got
the you know the call into his office I
knew like yeah he's he's headed my way
yeah you mentioning eight-foot which was
obviously giant gonzales yes I tried to
tell the story really quickly I remember
he came in about the same time that
Yokozuna came in and like I I had known
yoko from japan and seen him work over
there as Coquina maximus and i display i
was always just enthralled amazed how
good a worker he was and how well he
moved for the size he was and anyway he
was doing a dark match he had signed but
he was doing a dark match I think we
were in Baltimore and so there's there's
a stage there in Baltimore that you can
go out and you can kind of peek through
the curtain and watch and no one sees
you and so I'm I see events standing
there and he's watching Yoko work and I
come stand next to Vince and we're both
watching him and just you know watching
some of the stuff that he's doing that
these kicks that he's throwing and how
agile he moved 400 pounds and I remember
I remember just stopping and turning my
head and looking at Vince and I was like
please please please please let me work
with him first and you know fencing and
it's Vince laughs oh you you'll work
with him in time but I got somebody else
in mind for you and I kid you not coming
down the hall it from the other
direction
come here comes giant gonzales right he
goes that's your guy and I was like
because I got a little bit of taste of
giant goods all
when we are in WCW together right
another reason why I left because they
were trying to get me in a program down
there and maybe you didn't realize you
didn't realize all the giant Gonzales
needed was a full bodysuit with fur in
all it was so bad so many levels
so when you first so you did you got him
first and you get through your match at
WrestleMania 9 and you're like okay I
did it
we got through it it was a WrestleMania
match and we did it and it was big and
it's over and we are good when you find
out we're doing it again at SummerSlam
do you go what do I have to do man I
tell you what that whole thing took
years off my career I mean I would be I
would be a much better shape now if I
could have skipped that that one program
yeah it was as physically demanding as
it was it was it was twice the mental
strain because you know you guys out you
know you got Bret's there and now yo
goes there all these guys are going out
having these great matches and obviously
you want to be in you want to be
mentioned in the same breath with those
guys and it was just it was just not
possible it was survival every night
trying to we're just trying to figure
out what you know what he could do and
and you know and it took me that I had
to you know cuz Oh at that time I didn't
sell a lot and bump around and but man I
was flopping and you know just trying to
you know I was trying to make chicken
salad out of chicken crap it was it did
help me and it prepared me later on for
being able to work with with people
obviously with literally anyone who yeah
with cold sweats yeah that's got to be
number one you feel like you can
literally work with anyone and number
two when you finally do start having
these matches that people are like
that's the greatest wrestling match of
all time you're going well yeah I earn
the right to
that match okay do you know what I had
to go through to get here no doubt man
it was you know after a while like you
know you work that gimmick and then you
really it was always about the gimmick
really and so it really didn't matter
who he who he plugged in against it
it was me working the gimmick and then
obviously you know chokeslams and doing
all that but when I finally got at a and
I think it was I want to say was Bret
Hart who was one of the first guys that
I got to work with you know and Brett
didn't really want to you know he didn't
really want to change his style too much
to kind of cater to the Undertaker
character so it was my first chance
really to to actually work work and then
I had to figure out okay now can you
work the gimmick and then work a
wrestling match and I had some really
really good matches with Brett that I'm
really proud of where that kind of
started becoming I felt was kind of
where I started getting more tetter
Talent and then obviously that went into
the early Shawn Michaels stuff and I was
like yeah this is this is pretty cool so
if you have anything when I was young
when I was young and really healthy I
wasn't taking a lot of bumps and as I
got older more beat up the more bumps I
took and I had the whole thing mixed up
I did it I did it backwards
cousin tree starting to dupe launches
and stuff like that you're like now that
I've gotten beat up a little bit let me
let me throw some lucha in here yeah why
did you have any hideous ideas like
before you actually found this this
character were there any hideous ideas
you're like oh God thank God that that
never took off well only the one that I
created in my head so I'm sure you've
probably heard the story of Eggman by
now but no so what Vince did the he did
the buildup
the time that I that I debuted at
Survivor Series in in 90 you know they
had to build up for the the giant egg on
set and they were building up and I was
I had convinced myself without anybody
saying a word to me that I was gonna be
coming out of that egg and that I'd be
egg man like I was at that point where I
was trying to let my hair grow out you
know I was working on my look and all
that other stuff and this is even before
Undertaker was even ever that ever had
breath you know breathed into it so
there's this egg on the set every week
right and I'm just I'm at home like
watching I'm like oh I'm gonna be I'm
gonna come out of that egg and I know
it's gonna be me I'm gonna come out of
that egg he's gonna make me shave my
head and I'm gonna shave my eyebrows and
I'm gonna be a man I was honestly
working myself up into a nervous panic
and finally one day the phone the phone
rang and I got up because we didn't have
cell phones I got it
got up went answered the phone and it
was like I was like Hello what he goes
is this the Undertaker and I'm like
Undertaker Undertaker Undertaker's not
Eggman and it took me a second to
realize it was Vince right and I was
like that's yes sir this is the
Undertaker yeah honestly I honestly bout
get myself an ulcer worried about
becoming Eggman and but that was the
gobbly [ __ ] er the gobbly [ __ ] er was in
the egg and believe it or not the
Undertaker seemed to have more legs than
the gobbledygook ur character I would I
don't know who would have called it but
but but the Undertaker had legs yet
served up later that night one of the I
mean things that makes you you is you're
the one guy who stuck around you're the
guy who
consistently was with WWE from 1990
until now you're really the only person
they can say that you were that person I
mean Shawn never went to WCW but he was
gone for a period of time you the fact
that you never went to WCW though he's a
pretty big deal because everybody went
to WCW was there any point in your
entire run especially as hot as WCW is
getting with the NWO with Hulk Hogan
with all that stuff was there ever even
did it cross your mind was there a
moment where you were like you know I'm
closer now than I have been yeah there
was a time I was so frustrated I was so
frustrated with our creative direction
like we had a bunch of really goofy
characters and and then they're down
there doing some really like you know
real angles and you know and it was
common knowledge that they basically
opened up the checkbook and you know and
I'm having this you know I'm having to
hear guys you know talking about the
money that they're making and I'm like
my gosh you know what you'd be able to
you know you'd be able to write a pretty
good check and stay at home most of the
time and so those thoughts were there
but when it really got down to it you
know I just I said I can't I can't as as
I'm and obviously I'm not the best
businessman but you know there's just
something inside of me that said you
can't you can't leave here and there's a
couple of things one when I was there
and although the the management had
changed at this point while I was there
I went in to renegotiate a contract my
first I've been there for eight or nine
months my deal was coming up and I was
just going in try to get a little bit of
bump in the money right I was on the
bare bare minimum deal what looking to
you know what looking to break the house
but I go in and meet with Jim herd Olli
Anderson and Jim Barnett met with
they're downtown Atlanta I go in and you
know they're thinking well we're gonna
we're gonna resign you to the same deal
I was like well as you know I've had a
pretty good you know I've had a good
pretty good year here and as far as
where I was on the card and everything
and I was like I was I was hoping to get
a little bit of a bump in pay they
looked at me straight in the eyes and
said son you know you're a great athlete
but no one will ever pay money to see
you wrestle huh I just sit in the room
right I'm like right Wow okay now what
do you do like you know on the inside
like I knew right then like my days here
are numbered because I have a ceiling
you know they've already kept me out it
we're at what I can do and and who I can
be here and then you know fortunately I
got the I got the meeting with Vince and
as soon as I got the meeting with events
I was like okay well I got this meeting
with Vince they'll hire me Square you
know straight away so I give my notice
just on the meeting I go have the
meeting with Vince at the end of the
meeting he goes well and it was at the
house it was at his house too right so I
go I go have this meeting and at the end
of the meeting goes well we don't really
have anything for you right now I was
like okay didn't plan on that one either
like you broke up with a girl before you
had a new girlfriend at the time but
obviously eventually calls me and he's
like look I'm gonna give you an
opportunity to do something and that by
him giving me the opportunity and after
what you know the other guys had said to
me I was like this is you know obviously
and then you know
Undertaker happened and and we're off
and running I was just like I can't
leave I just my mom my loyalty to him
for giving me that opportunity was more
than you know the short-term cash in
that I could have done by going back
down to WCW
so was that motivating or crushing when
they started when it was that motivating
or crushing when they said no one will
pay to see you restless or a party that
goes like ah god they're right or is
there a party that goes screw these guys
I'll show them no I mean it was it was a
definite hit to my pride for sure but at
that point I mean I was at that point I
was locked in I knew that this was what
I was gonna do and like I had that
passion bug and it just like okay I just
knew my days there were numbered right
and that I had no no I didn't ever
second-guess myself as like you know I
need to get a new job or go back to
school it was like okay I gotta make
some moves and and then but it was
always fuel it really was always fuel
I've never forgot it
obviously I'm bringing it up 30-plus
years later yeah but I've always you
know I've always had that in my back of
my mind like no one will ever pay to see
you wrestle from yeah exactly because
seven years later they're literally
putting an inflatable version of you
outside of arenas so they can tell the
world hey guess who's in here you know I
thought it's interesting we were talking
about like people that were brought in
to be your opponent right to be the next
monster that the Undertaker has to
conquer and you were also talking about
that kind of goofy era and how it got to
the point where you're like what are we
doing here creatively and I actually
think that for you what brought your
character kind of out of that goofy
territory and let's do Undertaker versus
Undertaker let's do Undertaker versus
John Gonzalez let's do wonder take I
think it was Mick Foley being brought in
and I think the Undertaker mankind feud
which you know if Mick Foley wasn't Mick
Foley could have just been another
somebody being brought in for the
Undertaker to compete with change I feel
like both of you guys forever do you
think I'm right about that and do you
have a favorite Mick Foley match man
you're dead-on with that and so I knew
we had worked a little bit together in
WCW who's Cactus Jack so
you know I knew what I knew what Mick
was about and I knew him as a little bit
as a person and then you know just kind
of like I always had confidence that
that that was going to work and but
you're right it I mean it had the
potential to be it had the potential to
be a you know stinker because his
character if he hadn't had done his
character so well right you know that
was the thing you had a bunch of guys
doing silly characters that they didn't
they didn't have a clue how to work they
didn't want to be working these
characters but he he embraced the
embrace to mankind and made it his own
and it allowed us to do things you know
as far as violence and and physicality
that people hadn't really ever seen so
it was it was a breath of fresh air to
me and I think that was a very pivotal
part and part of any and The Undertaker
lore was the whole mankind angle and man
I there's so much stuff that we did you
know the boiler room brawl and hell in
the cell yeah I mean when you think
about it it's like the boiler room bra
is what made it so that you and Paul
Bearer weren't connected anymore and
then when you come back at Survivor
Series that's when you've shed kind of
the purple and black cartoon Undertaker
that we know and that's when the
all-black and the leather and the
teardrop and all that stuff and I feel
like that's really the evolution of the
character but like speaking of howling
us outright you've got this guy you're
wrestling the Helena cells probably I
mean it's to me I believe it's the most
famous wrestling match for non wrestling
fans everybody know is you know about
that match there's a folklore behind it
you're wrestling that match with a
broken foot you've already thrown Mick
Foley off the thing he's crashed through
the table we knew this was gonna happen
when there's that moment when he goes
through the cell which was the was not
supposed to happen he hits that ring and
really at that point only you and him
know how badly that's gonna hurt most of
the fans at home are still like oh it's
like a trampoline that wrestling ring
they don't know that it's like hitting
concrete and that
chair hits him on the way down and
everything and you you at that point
realized that the crowd doesn't know
that something's gone horribly wrong and
your friend is hurt for sure and you're
sitting now on top of this structure and
you don't know what to do what's going
through your head I was honestly I was I
was trying to to focus and hope that he
was can move he's honest that that was I
mean I was really close to being
catastrophic it really was and you know
he don't like I said he'd already taken
the bump off the top and and although
that would you know although that was
that was planned that was no easy I mean
it's not easy to do and it ain't easy on
the body and then this happens and he
landed man he'd landed in such a funky
way you know I was I didn't know I
didn't know that he was gonna get up and
so you know I'm having to think like
okay I need I need to get down there for
one and check on him but and I was I was
legit
I was legit scared for for what you know
what the results were gonna be he just
is a tough son of a gun man I don't you
know most people don't get up from that
like he did I mean you know get up and
finish the match and I'm telling I'm
trying to talk to him and I'm like Nick
let's go let's go home all he wanted to
do is that we got to get to the tacks
we got to get to the tacks I'm like are
you [ __ ] me really I'm looking at is
you know I had no idea what that what it
was at the time but it is like you know
his tooth went through his lip yeah I
got lodged in his nostril right and he's
you can look in his eyes and tell you
there was nobody home but he knew that
he had to get to the thumbtacks and that
was the finish and I was pleading with
him there's like man MIT can we can we
go home because you can
tell that you know he was not there and
tough dude man really honestly I don't
know if there's anybody you know any
tougher anybody else that would have the
no sense of responsibility to even try
and finish that match well we got a rap
you this has been awesome I mean this is
a you know as Jim knows I've been I've
interviewed just about every
professional wrestler on the planet and
you are the every time anybody's ever
asked who's the one guy that you have an
interviewed who's the one guy you'd like
to interview Undertaker is always the
name and now you've crossed that name
off the list so we really both
appreciate you being on the show
I appreciate the last ride the
docu-series is incredible episode 4
premieres on the WWE Network on Sunday
and real quick I'm watching episode 3 I
think it was episode 3 and you're
talking about the relationship with with
Shawn and Triple H and you and you're
talking about the moment that you guys
had at WrestleMania after the second
match with Triple H and the moment that
the three of you have on that stage and
this docu-series is kind of about you
chasing what is the moment that is gonna
cap off your career is there any part of
you that is worried wait a minute maybe
that was the moment yeah obviously
because that that that moment was
organic it wasn't planned it was it
really was just something that happened
you know after that I guess that angle
was four years in the bill you know -
Shawn - it
ends up with all three of us up there at
the top of the stage and ya know you
could kind of you know look in my eyes
and I'm looking around even while we're
up there and I'm enjoying the moment
that I had with these two guys which I
hold up most respect for but I'm also
looking around like does it get any
better than this right you know does it
get any better and obviously you know
obviously we know I kept going but it
was it was definitely one of those
moments and I had and I had the moment
with the
a match with Sean Mike yeah how does it
how you have to you know I'm looking
down the road like okay who else is left
that I can have this kind of match with
anyway you know I mean there's not a lot
of Shawn Michaels I mean there's some
really good talent but there's not a lot
of Shawn Michaels and Triple H's out
there left and but just you know for
whatever reason I kept rolling and and
and here we are so but that make you
talk to you that's one of the most
special moments of my career is being on
stage with those three guys at the end
of you know of an all out in our in our
profession of war yeah yeah but we let
you go one question would you be open to
the idea of you and I hanging out just
to upset Sam yeah would really hurt him
appreciate the time guys thanks and I
apologize again for being a little late
man I was great talking to no worries
yeah nice talking to you guys y'all have
a good day all right have a go and thank
you thanks